depuis des mois il ne se passe pas une
semaine sans qu'une nouvelle polémique
impliquant les forces de l'orde éclate
accusations de violences à de supposées
raciste bas durant mais que se
passe-t-il vraiment ces dernières années
le mouvement des gilet jaune n'a rien
arrangé des tensions entre la police et
la population française se voit accuser
de débordements lors de ces
rassemblements
les policiers sont même à plusieurs
reprises devenu la cible de france est
en colère contre une police qu'il juge
trop violente
selon des études rapprocher par le
criminologue sébastien roché la france
se situe dans le tiers inférieur de
l'union européenne pour la qualité de la
relation entre police et population
et si les violences policières sont un
véritable sujet notamment avec des
images de violences policières qui
circule de plus en plus sur les réseaux
sociaux comme avec l'histoire de michel
éclair hier soir le magazine envoyé
spécial revenait aussi sur cette affaire
en divulguant de nouvelles informations
mais c'est clair ils m'ont dit que
d'emblée quand il contrôle et vous
l'insultez de récemment c'est la sphère
de viry châtillon qui revenue sur le
devant de la scène avec la condamnation
de cinq jeunes et l'équipement de huit
autres un verdict qui a déclenché la
colère des syndicats des forces de
l'ordre aujourd'hui on peut plus se
permettre d'avoir une telle justice sac
la justice il faut appeler un chat un
chat
elle ne fait pas son travail donc il
doit le faire à doit rater d'être
clémente et à doigts sévèrement
sanctionné que ce soir camille chaise
porte parole du ministère de l'intérieur
est avec nous pour réagir aux nombreuses
polémiques sur la police
merci d'être avec nous camichel porte
parole du ministère de l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
vous avez vu l'émission hier soir envoyé
spécial c'est mon métier de regarder ce
qui concerne la police les sapeurs
pompiers voilà autour des braseros l'on
regarde c'est normal donc il ya
obligatoirement vous avez regardé alors
on va regarder un premier extrait il ya
une image voilà incroyable c'est l'image
et c'est ce qu'on apprend que l'un des
policiers mis en examen pour les
violences sur michel éclairs ont rappelé
michel est clair ce producteur de
musique qui était venue témoigner
chez nous en novembre avait dans son
portable un mot un montage qui pose
problème et qui fait posé énormément de
questions regarde la justice a saisi le
téléphone d'antoine ces messages photos
les vidéos et changer dessine-t-il le
profil d'un policier aux arrières
pensées racistes
deux éléments daté de cinq mois avant
l'agression était extrait de son
téléphone d'abord cette photo de georges
floyd tué par un policier blanc
on peut lire cette légende quand tu
dégonfle son matelas en fin de soirée
autre élément qui intéresse la justice
une discussion privée entre antoine est
une proche je suis vraiment désolé que
les français soient aussi content que tu
vives des violences comme ça tu ne
mérites pas ce ne sont pas des français
madame je suis dégoûté que tous ces
bâtards soit acceptée en france et que
l'on fait rien voilà qu'est ce que vous
avez réagi de certainement dans votre
post hier en voyant ça c'est que votre
action déjà d'être d'être choqués d'être
terrifiée à la fois par cette bêtise et
parce ses idées racistes qui sont une
fois de plus pas qu'une opinion est
raciste c'est un déni et donc quand les
policiers les gendarmes voient ça ils
sont ils sont dégoûtés quand ils font
bien leur travail en fait qu'on compare
tout la police et toute la gendarmerie à
ses policiers là qu'ils sont racistes
qui sont misogynes qui sont ces nos
folles c'est pas normal
il y en a il faut lutter contre ce
racisme dans la police mais il faut
aussi rendre leur fierté à tous ceux qui
font ça vous avez conscience que ce
genre de reportage ce genre de
comportement de ces policiers c'est
traîner un climat une idée reçue qui qui
voilà qu'on entend de plus en plus ce
soit sur les réseaux sociaux
dans la vraie vie qui dit la police est
raciste qu'elle quand vous entendez ça
me fait bondir
oui ça me fait bondir parce qu'il ya
plein de cas est plein de situations
différentes et ça existe dans la police
et faut lutter contre et moi je suis la
première à être terrifié quand je vois
ce type de comportement et de ce type de
mot le mot [__] le mot [__] ces
démos que moi qui suis policière je n'ai
jamais prononcé de ma vie c'est
inadmissible alors oui moi je pense à
tous les policiers qui font bien leur
boulot et qui trouvent que on dit que ça
2 et voilà ça me fait de la peine parce
que tous les jours quand on est en
commissariat qu'on accueille des femmes
victimes qu'on fait son travail dans les
quartiers difficiles eh ben eh ben c'est
ça fait mal au coeur pour ces policiers
d'être comparé à ça et ça c'est pas ma
police est pas ma police république ce
que c'est vrai que moi je parlais avec
un ami dans la foi judy voilà qui a eu
des acquis qui habitent en banlieue etc
et il lui c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
mais que vous essayez pas de dialoguer
avec les politiques et me dit non on
peut pas dialoguer avec la police la
police elle est raciste
voilà c'est ça c'est ça c'est ce qui est
c'est vrai que ça il ya un énorme
travail à faire aussi de communication
de communication mais faut pas tout
mettre le dossier de la communication la
vérité il faut que tous les policiers
les gendarmes au quotidien se comporte
bien aller dans la pédagogie explique
les choses on a
trop souvent l'impression que ont fait
respecter la loi parce que c'est la loi
mais encore la loi faut l'expliquer faut
échanger il faut expliquer pourquoi
quand on en fera une règle ça met en
danger la société etc
donc il faut rétablir ce dialogue
notamment dans l'est dans les quartiers
les plus difficiles
et voilà moi je suis là aussi pour
rendre hommage à tous les policiers les
gendarmes qui font bien leur boulot et à
dénoncer ces comportements une fois de
plus moi j'étais terrifiée horrifié
devant devant mon écran télé alors
justement je ne suis pas étonné on sait
que ça existe et il ya des affaires
judiciaires qui sont qui sont en cours
donc donc voila mais c'est déplorable
alors regardez ce policier est aussi
celui qui est suspecté d'avoir proféré
des insultes racistes contre michel est
clair lors de l'agression
et cet homme revient sur ce qui s'est
passé selon lui regarde on cherche à le
contacter parce qu'entraîneur manquer
sur le faire pour les lions ne s'est
clairement dit que d'emblée quand il
contrôle et vous l'insultez de synthèse
franchement niveau mais pas au 10 avril
c'est quoi je suis pas monsieur est
claire vallée noire du coup se passer
pour une victime mais c'est rien à voir
avec moi j'ai pour la contrôler parce
qu'il est noir on la contrôle des
comportements suspects filmés de prix
nous avait fait demi tour mais ont cessé
il a donné sa version donc ces voix-là 7
c'est bien aussi envoyé spécial d'avoir
été chercher la version de ce policier
il ya un autre extrait qu'est énormément
fait parler c'est ce témoignage très
fort d'alex un policier noir qui a
découvert un jour que ses collègues
proféré des insultes racistes à son
encontre
ça c'est l'extrait pour moi le plus fort
de l'émission d'hier
regardez alex est un gardien de la paix
discret de 43 ans dont vous ne verrez
pas le visage pour des raisons de
sécurité il s'est procuré les centaines
de messages racistes que s'échangent à
une dizaine de ses collègues
certains de ces messages et ne visait
directement alex qu'on regarde et le
nombre d' insulte aux victimes
j'étais partagé entre garder mon calme
pété un câble en fait ça détruit un
homme ça c'est l'extrait le plus
choquant le plus violent cc je vous
avais même vous vous aimez suis très
choqué en regardant mon en voyant cet
extrait et c'est vrai qu'on dit qu'il ya
du racisme dans la police ce que vous en
avez conscience ou qui avait été
d'ailleurs sur le terrain voilà donc
est-ce qu'il y en avait au est-ce que
c'est une idée reçue ou pas plus
qu'ailleurs où on voit là qu'est ce que
vous avez répondu il ya différentes
choses pour moi il n'y a pas de racisme
systématiser ya pas une administration
qui l'est ce cher qui ferment les yeux
ça c'est pas vrai nous la hiérarchie les
commissaires les officiers de police de
gendarmerie les majors on est là pour
vérifier qu'ils aient pas ce type de
choses
après des fois dans des brigades dans
des groupes il ya certaines valeurs qui
sont mises en avant des valeurs de
virilité
des fois on met en avant la brutalité on
montre ses muscles et c est ça il faut
aussi lutter conte parce que c'est de là
que naît toutes les discriminations
alors on parle du racisme mais il ya
aussi la misogynie l'homophobie tout ça
ça va ensemble c'est des comportements
marlène schiappa désiré de relou voit là
aussi il ya des événements ou des choses
qui sont des faits délictuels grave et
qu'il faut dénoncer et bravo à ce
policier de l'avoir dénoncé
il ya des dispositifs qui existent dans
la police pour dénoncer ces faits on a
une plateforme qui s'appelle signal
discrimination quand on a l'impression
de subir une discrimination est poussé
en un sens ces plateformes c'est
toujours compliqué parce que si ça il
faut pas qu'ils aient d'omerta en auront
vécu en tant que femme des fois vous
avez voilà du sexisme des choses comme
ça faut pas laisser passer on a un
combat à mener en interne aussi et les
médias nous aide en mettant la pression
parce que cette omission ça met la
pression et c'est bien aussi de rappeler
l'importance d'être exigeants et d'être
déterminé dans cette lutte contre le
racisme je sens du verbe et j'entends
parfaitement madame et il faut attendre
un reportage d'envoyé spécial il faut
attendre des faits divers dramatiques on
a l'impression que vous agissiez il ya
des groupes
whatsapp ultra raciste qu'est ce que
vous faites quand un policier dénonce on
le voit dans le reportage plutôt que de
lui donner une promotion
il est sanctionné parce qu'il a dénoncé
des retards il faut
aidez à dénoncer les brebis galeuses est
ce que vous faites vraiment tout ce
qu'il faut alors il ya trois choses
qu'on fait il ya un contrôle
hiérarchique sur le terrain il faut que
les majors les grades et les
commissaires isaï dans toutes les
brigades pour voir les gens alors vous
allez dire quand le chef est pas là et
il se passe des choses quand le chef et
là ça se passe pas et puis après il ya
des procédures administratives
judiciaires qui prennent du temps on
rassemble les preuves parce que c'est
comme ça que marche la justice en france
il faut des preuves alors là il ya des
messages à des boîtes sont donc il ya
une procédure judiciaire qui met
plusieurs mois et c'est pour ça que que
ça prend du temps après on n'attend pas
envoyé spécial on n'attend pas les
médias pour le faire en revanche c'est
bien qu'il ya un contrôle démocratique
aussi des médias des parlementaires de
groupes extérieurs d'association et à
l'association flag par exemple qui
bossent contre l'homophobie dans la
police c'est bien qu'ils aient tous ces
contre-pouvoirs pour maintenir la
pression après voilà je pense qu'on est
aussi à l'image de la société il ya du
racisme dans la société il y en a dans
la police c'est encore plus
insupportable quand c'est des policiers
ces eaux qui font respecter la loi qui
font en sorte que les gens sont protégés
donc c'est encore plus inadmissible et
vraiment c'est un combat de lutter
contre le racisme dans la police juste
quelques chaises on a vu aussi ses ces
émeutes dans les banlieues voilà tous et
ça n'arrête pas c'est tous les jours est
ce que vous vous rendez compte aussi de
la détresse des policiers parce que l'on
parle voilà de brebis galeuses aussi
voilà qui font du mal à la police comme
je le dis à chaque fois la police c'est
comme moi je sais comme népal et mes
potes l'élégie des jaunes voilà je le
dis il ya 95% de bougies les jaunes et y
en a 5 % c'est pas de gilet jaune c'est
des mecs qui entre la mer et à la dent
la police ya 95% des gens qui font bien
leur travail à 1 à 5% qui se prennent
pour des cow boys qui font beaucoup de
mal aux 95 % même s'ils sont une
minorité et oui c'est juste sauf que
dans le sur france 2 on n'augmente pas
les flics qui sont effectivement des
bons citoyens qui font beaucoup de
choses pour tout c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai que là c'est sûr avec vous l'âge et
puis j'ai vu en replay j'étais choqué
évidemment c'est honteux
mais quand on a vraiment on appelle si
la police peut pas aimer la police
et dire que les molécules et fixons des
rats 6 x terra affectivement il ya
peut-être deux trois et parle de dix
personnes s'est pas non plus si c'est
moi j'aurais aimé je sais ça j'aurais
juste aimé qui lui s'est une fois de
plus celle face à un sujet ont raison il
ya ce problème parce que c'est un
problème depuis mai à temps c'est pas
mal ça fait 30 ans mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que je chante un peu d'accord
avec avec benjamin
c'est un peu c'est un peu démago et
démago lancé à l'univers soir je le dis
parce que voilà on nous montre et c'est
comme quand on fait les jeunes de
banlieue les jeunes de banlieue quand on
y avait vu un reportage sur des jeunes
de banlieue où il ya une entraide
incroyable en banlieue où il ya des
malades sont des trucs formidables où il
ya des coups énormes réussite en
banlieue et à chaque fois les reportages
qui est toujours sur les violences dans
les banlieues les dîneurs et abel
shabbat sur les police sur la police
séparaient toujours à 20 jours c'est
toute sa charge
c'est toujours que c'est vrai qu'à un
moment c'est vous dire ça fait du mal
pour moi c'est ça tournait à la
république a fait du mal à tout le monde
parce que ça les autorités la banque les
gens les uns contre les autres c'est ça
est ce que pour vous c'est bon ou c'est
mauvais de diffuser des livres des
reportages comme ça sur france
télévision en prime time
le problème c'est que la plupart des
téléspectateurs après avoir vu ça ils
pensent que tout la police elle est
raciste
allez misogyne et sexiste elle est
homophobe et c'est tout l'inversé en
fait les policiers
tous les matins il se lève et leurs
moteurs c'est de servir les gens d'aider
les victimes de recueillir les femmes
violentées vont intervenir trop beagle
ya des brebis galeuses du racisme il y
en a dans la société y en a dans
l'hérault lycée faut lutter contre après
ma police républicaine c'est parce qu'on
a vu hier soir claire oui c'est sûr oui
mais ça existe aussi les distos il faut
lutter knock non mais sérieusement c'est
bien de le dénoncer et c'est bien se
douter mais il faut montrer aussi voilà
allez des gens qui est qu'ils aiment
leur métier et qui font leur métier par
passion et qui se lève pas le matin en
se disant je vais faire une bavure voilà
où je vais avoir la haine raciste ou ou
autrui et pardon mais l'angle
journalistique pour moi il est absurde
se demander si la police est raciste la
police c'est pas un parti politique ce
n'est pas un groupement idéologique
c'est un métier on se demanderait pas si
les boulangers sont racistes par exemple
que c'est absurde de poser cette
question et à charmant il ya du racisme
mais ce sont des cas isolés ce sont des
brebis galeuses et ses terribles qui
nuisent à l'image des deux cent mille
policiers en france dont je pense que la
majorité n'est absolument pas raciste
pour mes services de me faire ça camus
camille chaise est-ce qu'il ya encore
des jeunes qui veulent devenir policier
ouais ya plein de jeunes qui veulent
devenir un bon lycée alors là on a des
concours qui sont ouverts gardiens de la
paix sous-officier de gendarmerie
et là on a lancé un plan qu'on a appelée
dîme il est jeune on recrute dix mille
jeunes pour des stages d alternance pour
aussi faire venir encore envie de dans
la paix bien sûr c'est même un contre un
concours assez sélectif assez difficile
après tout notre enjeu c'est d'abord une
police qui ressemble à la société avec
des femmes avec
jeunes de tous horizons de toutes
catégories socioprofessionnelles des
quartiers aussi et c'est là que ça
devient difficile parce que quand un
jeune de banlieue ils voient l'émission
je sais pas s'il regarde france 2 envoyé
spécial je suis pas alors il ya les
audiences n'étaient pas terribles
voilà un virgule le jeune équipe et sur
l'air sur les jeunes il a pas forcément
envie d'être policier non c'est là que
c'est déplorait je vous dire hier ça ça
voilà c'était pas les jeunes nous
regarder cette émission camichel c'est
quoi votre parcours juste pour que les
jeunes qui nous regarde voilà se disent
peut-être que on peut
non mais c'est vrai voilà comment elle
peut voilà vous êtes aujourd'hui porte
parole du ministère de l'intérieur que
rentrer dans la police après sa paume ni
à chaque lancer dans l'humanitaire en
fait j'ai la russie pour une ong qui
s'appelait save the children qui
s'occupait notamment des réfugiés voilà
j'ai travaillé comme secourisme à la
croix rouge française c'était mon
premier job et j'ai fait cinq ans comme
pompier réservistes la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris
et puis j'ai voulu et des victimes
autrement devenant policiers et voilà
aujourd'hui je porte la parole dont je
représente tous les agents du ministère
de l'intérieur préfectures
sous-préfectures pompiers policiers
gendarmes et j'en oublie plein je
m'excuse auprès de ceux que bien sûr oui
il a effectivement il faudrait peut-être
dire aussi élise lucet de faire des
émissions où on honore les policiers les
pompiers richard goode moi je pense à
nador à jamais et qu'elle évacuerait
accroc très déçu si c'est bien ce qu'a
choisi mes amis s'est pas senti chez moi
à ce qu'air france avait il ya quatre
mois et demi j'ai des gars qui étaient
là sur ce plateau non expliqué son
histoire elle arrive en zorro
excusez moi c'est à gerber excusez moi
c'est pas bien de faire ça d'abord si
une chaîne publique
donc au moins tu donnes ou moins le pour
et le contre mais c'est pas normal
franchement et elle est toujours en
zorro elle est toujours chargée et la
police allaient comme ci comme ça elle
est homophobe c'est pas bien après ce
faux culs possible de groupe à la
dénoncer certaines choses qui ont fait
avancer les choses
après comme on lui dit à chaque fois à
élise lucet pourquoi elle ne fait pas
justement un envoyé spécial ou voilà où
un seul des gens
sur les châssis vous rassemblez ouais
quand on veut faire république et fauqué
des gens de tous horizons ils se
rassemblent autour de projets communs et
ça ça ferait du bien la sauce moi je
vais vous dire qu'à michel une personne
qui s'est arrêtée aujourd'hui après
avoir vu le reportage
je vais vous dire elle amplifie la
population alors je me suis très bien ce
que vous faites vous êtes des pourris
c'est pas byzance et il est logique de
confrontation clairement fou déchets ce
que c'est vrai et moyens soir quand j'ai
regardé c'était tellement à charge
contre lui la police nationale c'était
l'amicale du cul du clan quoi c'était à
bien attendez les propos alors les
propos était odieux mais bon moi je
connais les policiers j'aime et qui mois
certains je l'aurais je les ai appelés
jeudi t'as vu le reportage sur les
spéciales et une émission est parce qu
en fait à cause d'une bande d'abrutis
voilà on va tous passer pour des jeux ou
des noirs il ya le même problème sur m6
avec enquête exclusive et bernard de la
villardière je lis toujours à chasser
les bombarde
sur l'île c'est relou sur les voilà sur
les les musulmans et c'est vrai qu'il ya
ce problème là et france télé c'est la
police est tous des pourris et sur m6
avec berlin l'année dernière ont caché
deux jours sur les mêmes et ce alors je
vous le dis pour moi c'est pour moi
c'est pas moi après font ce qu'ils
veulent je suis pas assez quand vous
donnez des conseils de télévision
vraiment et je me garderais bien d'en
faire
voilà c'est pas moi de me dire merci en
tout cas qu'à michetz d'abord
et on aimerait vraiment mais vraiment
qu'un jour il y ait vraiment une reprise
du dialogue entre les jeunes et la
police ça serait vraiment le je pense
que c'est le travail le plus important à
faire au ministère après je pense que
vous avancez autour de ça mais vraiment
il ya un dialogue parce que quand on
discute avec les aînés les jeunes de
banlieue je peux vous dire ils n'ont
qu'une envie aussi
c'est un exemple pour terminer bien sûr
je lance à dana partie exemple là tout à
l'heure j'ai reçu cinq jeunes d'une
association qui s appelle espoir 18 ils
sont super et on a parlé ensemble
pendant une heure de la police et des
relations avec les jeunes de banlieue là
ils sont du xviiie arrondissement et ils
ont été visité le commissariat du 18ème
je leur ai fait visiter le ministère de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui voilà ça c'est
un exemple concret il ya du dialogue cd
petite goutte d'eau dans la mer mais
c'est comme ça qu'on fait choisir je
suis à ses lecteurs et en s'écoutant
mais chez les éclairs qui est ici il ya
eu un discours fabuleux sur le web
voilà quand il a dit voilà moi j'ai
plein de potes policier la police et
fait bien son travail à 95% et là où le
rire et les rôles hilarants
voilà et c'est vrai que échoue il dit
c'est pareil pour les jeunes de banlieue
qu'on stigmatise à chaque fois il y en a
beaucoup qui n'ont aucune qui n'ont
qu'une envie c'est de réussir c'est de
faire des choses bien et qui font des
choses bien d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de réussite en banlieue on le
montre jamais il faudra peut-être qu'on
fasse un programme un jour avec un
succès vite avec menahem à la
présentation parce qu'elle représente
le problème c'est avec grand plaisir
c'est notre vie